hi i'm reza aslan and i'm raine wilson
and i'm rayne wilson and i'm rayne
wilson and i'm rayne wilson what is what
is happening what's going on what are
you doing oh it's just me and all
myselves and all our parallel universes
oh boy here we go
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
[Music]
pancakes science
he blinded me with science
you and i are scientific guys people you
know we're spiritual guys but we're
scientific guys too like i mean i think
well what does that mean scientific
means we i mean i read the occasional
science blog on the new york times or
something but i guess what i mean by
that is that
we take very seriously
uh science is a methodology sure the
idea that you observe certain phenomena
you
theorize about the causes yeah of the
those phenomena
you you want to replicate it yeah you
replicate it you you exactly you you
test it out
and then you know you sort of plant your
flag on things that are
real and and fact-based
while at the same time in our case
also being open to
the mysteries of the universe and a
spiritual perspective and a a longing
for transcendence and and uh the taking
seriously the idea of a creator with a
will and you know all those things that
seem
i think on the outside fairly
unscientific but that's not how you and
i think but you know there's a lot of
science to spirituality itself right
isn't there a
kind of a scientific method to
spirituality in a weird way like hey
this works and makes me happy and makes
me more fulfilled and makes me feel more
connected and i feel more in my purpose
when i do x y and z oh so let me
replicate x y and z oh does it still
make me feel that way oh it does then
there must be some spiritual truth to
that that's a really good point and i
think that also i think contradicts how
non-spiritual people sometimes
think about spiritual people you know
like the idea that
they think
that's because sam harris thinks you're
native let's just face it
that's what i'm trying to say basically
is that um
that i think there's this assumption
that if you you know believe in god or
if you are religious or if you
you know uh long for a spiritual
edification that you have no systematic
approach exactly that you're
unreasonable that you're irrational that
that you were superstitious evidence
yeah right right or the flip side of
that which also drives me so crazy
sometimes is the belief that oh if i
could just
show you evidence
that contradicts your your spiritual
nature
that you won't be spiritual anymore
which again is just such a
misunderstanding of yeah of the
spiritual perspective right i mean i
often say that
if aliens suddenly showed up you know
from alpha centauri isn't that a place i
thought it was a place
and just kind of came into this studio
and introduced themselves could we get
them for the podcast amy do you think we
can get the aliens number one we'd book
them i have to sign a release and i
don't know if aliens
know how to sign and number two
uh that wouldn't in any way contradict
you know people's religions christians
would be like oh now there's aliens i'm
still a christian this has happened time
and time again listen um as soon as
darwin discovered evolution uh there was
a whole
ream of people that were like aha
religion has been disproved there is no
god because
we don't need a god of the gaps a god to
have created guppies and have created
lizards that crawled up on land and
created monkeys that then turned into
humans that this just happened through
science um and of course that's
preposterous and it's the same thing
when uh they discovered like the spot of
the brain with that experiences
spirituality and they have a brain scan
like oh look you're experiencing
spirituality here haha therefore we have
shown the materialist roots of
spirituality yeah and uh well of course
that's how it would work i mean would we
experience yeah i'm gonna experience
yeah in some magical fairy dust place uh
well i'll say one other thing that i've
noticed is that the more
science becomes theoretical the more it
starts digging deep into the very nature
of reality the more it sounds a lot like
spirituality
right the way that they use words to
kind of explain the nature of reality
the way that they accept certain
uh ideas that have absolutely no proof
you know right sort of traditional
string theory uh right spooky action at
a distance from quantum mechanics so i
guess fundamentally what we're saying
are science and religion a lot more
alike than we think
they are do they have a lot more in
common
than we just assume
that that they do i'm gonna say yes to
that but
why don't we ask our next guest yeah
somebody who actually knows what they're
talking about yeah as opposed to
me yeah
matt o'dowd
is a professor at lemon college part of
the city university of new york he's
also a resident research associate at
the american museum of natural history
but the reason we love him so much is he
is writer and host of this thing called
pbs space time
which is like this awesome delightful
show that's on youtube and it explains
very complex
uh scientific issues and easy to
understand language and he's a handsome
man he's a good-looking awesome
good-looking guy yeah i didn't know
aussies i didn't know scientists could
be from australia no no i think he's the
only one pretty much
pretty sure um but yeah and he also digs
into some topics that i would say are
metaphysical almost
parallel universes
multiverses
right so let's let's push him let's
let's get him to to help us figure out
what science and spirituality can
actually have in common with each other
[Music]
so matt this is really fascinating the
pew research did a stat that said that
73 of americans know the difference
between astronomy and astrology
which i guess is good news the bad news
being that 27 percent of americans don't
know the difference between australia i
think i've met that 27
uh whenever i tell someone what i do at
a at a party i i usually get asked to
like oh what sign are you
yeah what's tell me my future matt
exactly
but as an old friend as an old friend
told me
me not believing in astrology is so
capricorn of me
that's perfect so matt um
how did you get started in all of this
you astrophysicists kind of look at the
very largest questions of the universe
that's what reza and i are interested in
exploring the very largest questions of
the universe but those sometimes include
science and sometimes don't but why did
you choose the scientific path to
explore this
route so you know i grew up uh i grew up
catholic
and
in
any religion there there are there are a
lot of things and and one of the things
that that religions have are uh supposed
answers to the big questions
um at some point i realized that the
the particular tradition that i grew up
with some of the answers that it gave
didn't ring true
uh and so i realized i needed to expand
my horizons
to to pursue those answers why i needed
those answers i can't tell you
but
in a let's call it a gap year i dropped
out of high school i
started reading a lot of physics books
and i realized that somewhere
deep down there were at least
potentially some of the answers that i
sought
and
i just
jumped in
went back to school took the hardest
subjects and you know
it was brutal uh
didn't do that well but
slowly i started to get this impression
that that i was following a path where i
could better understand the universe um
and
eventually got a physics degree
decided
that this could be a hell of a life
you know pursuing these largest
questions and uh you know
to start with it was it was physics it
was reading the works of einstein and
heisenberg and and eventually
astrophysics took my heart because it
i mean it's clearly the coolest of all
of the branches
think about
right think about such a range of uh of
different um fields of physics i mean
think about it there's some like
physicists that are studying like
buoyancy losers you know like oh how
much water do i need
before this
thing floats to the top i'm just curious
like at conventions did the
astrophysicist get around and just bully
like all the other
uh physicists you know they're just like
you're a regular physicist yeah you're
just probably getting bullied all the
time
you know
as physicists
many of us were bullied and so we're
quite sensitive to that
one of the things that uh i think some
people who study both you know religion
and and science would say is that
they're fundamentally two different
modes of knowing right that they're
asking two
different questions that as you
kind of alluded to right there that um
what you were interested in was more uh
the question of how right which is why
you pursued the sciences um
but the question of why which is so much
about what religion talks about and and
that's what the metaphor and religion is
all about is the question of why is a
different question do you see a
necessary conflict between
religion and science i don't
subscribe to the the notion of this
this pure dichotomy
no scientists thinks in a you know this
this very regimented algorithmic way uh
purely exercising the scientific method
science is a a series of tools
and and checks
that you can pepper
your line of inquiry with your path of
of of coming to some knowing um and the
tools are designed to to shore up your
method to
you know create certainty where
otherwise you couldn't have it uh to to
give a structure that allows you to take
that line of inquiry much further but
nonetheless in
exactly the same way as as i think
occurs in religion
much of the work of of human inquiry is
about intuition it's about synthesizing
the information that comes in uh whether
it comes in consciously or not and
synthesizing it often unconsciously
yielding these incredible intuitions
these senses of truth which guide the
path of your study
and and to me the scientific method is a
way to
just
leverage that to add kind of this this
concreteness and and to add a type of
surety to
you know the questions and the you ask
and the answers that you reach that
allow a sharing uh of that method so
that others can build in in
i guess a way that is more certain than
i guess the the sort of stories that you
know building up on stories uh you know
and building upon the senses of truth
but only
in in what feels like a looser way uh as
occurs i guess in in what you might call
spiritual inquiry but one of the things
you said was is really interesting to me
is you were addressing us searching for
certainty and
i always view like the worst of religion
as being certainty you know when someone
says like i am the way in the light and
the only way to the father is through me
and that means you believe anything else
that you're going to hell and that gets
this kind of certainty that has a
rigidity to it um it's certainly not
what i ascribe to and what a lot of
spiritual people ascribe to but but how
do you achieve certainty in the study of
the universe because it seems to me like
the more i dive into anything science
related there's very little certainty in
fact we find something out you know i
grew up and the smallest possible thing
is a neutron there is nothing smaller
than that there is nothing smaller than
that and it's only matter and light and
energy in the universe and then all of a
sudden there's dark matter and dark
energy and there's neutrinos and there's
alpha particles or whatever that's
tinier than that and like all of these
kind of things we were certain about
have been completely
uh broken do you really feel like you're
going to get to a place where you have
certainty through science definitely not
uh and the fact that the view of the
world in which neutrons were the
smallest thing that the fact that that
was broken
is uh
i think a testament to the power of
science and and paradoxically the power
of science is to
embrace like vigorously embrace
uncertainty uh and
perhaps
the goal
ultimately is certainty or you know the
apex point is is certainty
but that's something we reach for it's
not something we expect to ultimately
achieve but what we do know is that
by
embracing the fact that we do not know
it does lead us closer to that point and
and so that's the aim to get closer and
closer and and we do i think you can't
deny that we understand the world vastly
better now than we did
50 years ago 100 years ago
sure and you know and for me i think
part of the problem is that many
scientists
are a little smug
about how
how their understanding of the universe
uh supersedes other understandings um
and i'm i'm guilty of that sometimes
myself uh but
i i really feel that you know i just
wish everyone was a little less certain
about their
their certainties i think
uh the fact that we can and and should
and must ask continue to ask questions
about things that we think we know
uh is critical uh and and to me that's
in that's integral to the scientific
method it's interesting the word that
caught my attention
when you were talking about sort of what
science is and isn't wasn't certainty it
was intuition that was the word that
that you know made me lift my
eyebrows because
so much of
particularly you know when you get to
astrophysics and you know theoretical
physics and uh when you're talking about
the nature of the the universe the stuff
that you know we love to talk about
so much of that is based on intuition
and not really observable
um fact
right sure um i mean you know we're
pretty
flawed entities you know as
assessors of truth observers of the
universe we're we're pretty flawed we're
we're massively biased and in all
different ways uh you know
evolutionarily and and
genetically and and and by our
upbringing and environments we
see a world which is only a a sliver of
the true world and we uh interpret it
massively you know it's a it's a skewed
perspective
but nonetheless we are you know we have
this
sense of of what is real and what is not
real we know when we're awake rather
than dreaming we
have this kind of truth organ in us you
know there's an expression when
something rings true it's an intangible
intuition that something's true
where does that come from it comes from
deep in our brain our brain is working
hard to
compare things to look for consistencies
in in what it knows and and it yields us
this this sense of truth when things
match up when its model of the universe
matches
uh the evidence uh
so you know that that's a bit of
speculative neuroscience there but but i
think it's reasonable uh so
we are intuiting things we don't
consciously go through all of the
process of every little
you know calculation of truth
but
but when we have them you know what they
can do is they can point us in the right
direction
and
i like to think of science as a
structure that we then build on that we
we have this kind of compass
which is our intuition of truth but we
we don't always know that it points true
sometimes we can have that falsely
you know long time listeners of the
metaphysical milkshake pod know that uh
quite some time ago i got my
mother-in-law story worth you know it's
this great uh service that helps
you or your loved one uh connect through
sharing stories and memories and then it
preserves them for years to come well
father's day is coming and i figured i
don't have any good ideas for a father's
day gift so why don't i give my
father-in-law story worth and that's
exactly what i did
every week story worth emails your loved
one a thought-provoking question of your
choice from a vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt asks
questions you've never thought of like
what is one of your fondest childhood
memories or have you ever feared for
your life so let me get this right after
one year story worth compiles all of
these anecdotes questions memories
stories including photos into a
beautiful keepsake book that's exactly
it it's an easy way to write their
biography that's how you should think
about it
perfect so give all the fathers in your
life a meaningful gift you can both
cherish for years to come story worth
right now for a limited time you can
save ten dollars on your first purchase
when you go to storyworth.com
milkshake that's s-t-o-r-y-w-o-r-t-h
dot com slash milkshake to save ten
dollars on your first purchase
storyworth.com
milkshake
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything you need and nothing you
don't that means lots of salt with no
sugar
in fact it contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio 1000 milligrams sodium
200 milligrams potassium 60 milligrams
magnesium and with none of the junk that
means no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten no fillers no bs
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and is
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet electrolyte
deficiency or imbalances can cause
headaches cramps fatigue and weaknesses
when you sweat the primary electrolyte
lost is sodium and you can lose up to
seven grams per day when sodium isn't
replaced it's common to experience
muscle cramps and fatigue now i'll tell
you something um as you know i play a
lot of tennis
and uh i started using element and i
just love it i when i've gone back to
other ones or someone has given me a
different kind of electrolyte powder for
my you know from my thermos bottle um i
it's just so sweet and you realize like
wait a minute i don't want to drink all
of that sugar element is so sure you
will love their product and come back
for more they are offering you a free
element sample pack that's eight single
serving packets free just cover the cost
of shipping it's five dollars for u.s
customers
get yours at drink
element dot com slash milkshake this
deal is not available on their regular
website you must go to
d-r-i-n-k l-m-n-t
get it element l-m-n-t dot com slash
milkshake element offers no questions
asked refunds try it totally risk-free
if you don't like it
share it with a salty friend and we'll
give you your money back no questions
asked you got nothing to lose folks
[Music]
you uh very humorously said you know
that um
you hate it when people
uh turn science into sort of pseudo
spirituality right that it that it
really bothers you um which i totally
get like the movie what the bleep do we
know right exactly yeah so basically the
kind of stuff that rayne and i do um
the reason for this podcast so um but i
wonder though like
the way i hear you talking
i and i really appreciate the sort of
the openness that you have about the
limits of scientific knowledge and the
fact that so much of it
is essentially
uh intuition that you know you begin
with a certain set of postulates
and then you sort of use those
postulates to point you generally
in a direction
and then you pursue you know the the
questions of how
within that path
and then also recognizing that you you
are willing to admit when you're on the
wrong path and you might turn around and
you might realize it's a dead end and
all of that stuff i guess what i'm what
i'm curious about is do you feel like
there is actually a valid intersection
between
and and more specifically quantum
physics astrophysics these sort of
larger scientific questions about the
nature of the universe and
um spirituality um is there a way to use
one to explore the other in other words
so the answer the short answer is yes uh
the slightly longer answer is what do
you mean by spirituality okay that's a
very good question yeah that's a good
question my explorations of the universe
which are technically scientific yet uh
peppered with moments of wild
intuition and speculation
feel spiritual especially you know
especially the good parts like
particularly the beginning in the end um
i think the
majesty and the beauty
and the complexity and and the surprise
and the mystery of our universe are
are as spiritual as any possible
religion and these are words that are so
often used in religion you know the
grandeur and the mystery
so in that sense and this has been said
by you know plenty of people including
carl sagan
it's a deeply spiritual endeavor
so i guess
is the question then uh
some of the notions that are typically
ascribed to spirituality like the the
notion of the soul or of god uh are they
in the purview of science
that's what you mean by god or the soul
we're defining all terms here but i will
say definition yes one of the first
things you said in this uh interview is
you talked about you know some of the
questions that were raised by your
catholic upbringing was like
why
is
why are we here why is there stuff why
is there a universe and there's two
approaches to that you can dig into the
facts of the big bang
and you can also kind of come at it from
a more
i don't know psycho-emotional standpoint
of like why is there a universe
you know and if there's why is there a
universe why do i have consciousness
why does this weird
white bloated suburbanite dad
have consciousness to have this
discussion right now he's particularly
bloated right now he's gained a lot of
weight this year actually thanksgiving
holidays amy's laughing at me
half the questions answered
the question is why and and you brought
up earlier the difference between the
the question why and how
uh and and
i'm not
so
inclined to separate the two as many
scientists many scientists
suggest that one should never ask why
only how uh i you know i think this is a
little semantic
and so i'm i'm not as interested in only
asking how it how what is the the
physical mechanism from going from this
to that you know especially if you're
going if you're trying to get back
before there was anything the the whole
notion of causality and physicality
starts to
starts to slip away
and so uh
you know that that's the point where
there's definitely a
very blurred line between the questions
of
what you might call religion and the
questions of science
but i
maintain perhaps unreasonably that
the
scientific method is
as i i think of it which is just a way
to
give your
you know your intuition and truth
compass some some rigor and
you know a check
i think that is still valid and i think
you know honestly i think
religious
inquiry or spiritual inquiry
accidentally uses a lot of what we think
of in the scientific method anyway which
is um you know chains of logic and cause
and effect
i think scientists science just tries to
take it a bit further
i say this all the time matt that's it's
exactly what i think that's kind of your
thing that's my whole thing i think a
lot of non-religious people and and many
in the scientific community think that
religious people
are irrational or
that
spiritual belief is is a sort of product
of a diseased mind
when
anybody who's ever studied religion or
religious people anyone can tell you
quite the contrary that there is an
enormous amount
of dealing with empirical evidence of
casting aside you know certain doctrines
or creeds that conflict with new
knowledge about the the workings of the
of the world the example that i always
use is the example of you know
recognizing that the earth is not the
center of the universe as most
scriptures say
you know religious people know that the
earth is not the center of the universe
they're religious anyway they still
follow their scriptures you know i think
there's this idea that the real division
between science and religion is that one
is based solely on evidence and facts
and one is based on
feelings and intuition when in reality a
lot of science as you've already said is
based on intuition and feelings and
more of religion than most people would
like to admit
is based on observable cause effect um
you know
empirical
experiences let me uh
add to that perhaps uh i would say that
all of science includes
intuition uh and creativity uh
but all of science also includes you
know certain
non-negotiable aspects of the scientific
method uh or or tools of science and so
all include both so what's the
difference
well
the difference is that
the scientific pursuit
is limited
to that which is observable
meaning
what you can experience with your
empirical senses and the spiritual
pursuit is not well tell that to a
string theorist okay so here's the thing
no the string theorist no i'm glad you
brought up absolutely
they're still in science departments uh
here's okay well here's a question for
you is there more proof
for a creator
or more proof for string theory
uh
stumped you that depends a little bit on
you
yay we did it
he paused for a few minutes to think
clearly okay thanks so much for calling
thanks everyone
this is a really big question because
uh
many many scientists would would say
that there is no more proof of string
theory than there is ever created but
but here you get to this very touchy
definition of proof
and you know the fact is that
many theoretical physicists go down
paths
which
are so far beyond testing
simply because
we can't build
the big enough particle accelerator in
any foreseeable generation
uh but that doesn't make you know that
doesn't make their lines of inquiry
invalid that that may be how the
universe actually is
um but
it it seems that we may need to reinvent
what we define as evidence in science i
think we may need to move beyond you
know sort of
as it was laid out by karl popper this
this sort of observational
imperative and and we may need to
talk about what it means for
for example
mathematics to converge in a very
consistent way on a particular picture
even if the
the way that that math was derived was
several layers removed from any
observation and we have
uh examples in history of scientists
moving this way of pursuing what you
might call beauty in the math
and mathematical convergence right
they really do and my favorite by far is
is paul dirac's uh discovery of
antimatter a few years before it was
discovered and he did so by pursuing a
beautiful equation that
would weave together einstein's special
relativity with with quantum theory
and he couldn't do it and he couldn't
make the equation pretty unless he made
certain really
you know guesses in the math that that
led to this this convergence and
the only reason that
he decided that this was right was
because the equation was beautiful and
his intuition
told him that this was this was you know
right there was some truth here
it predicted this mirror universe of
particles antimatter uh which a few
years later were uh were observed i bet
he used a lot of uh sixes and nines
because
when they fit together they're kind of
like sperm a little bit
and right on yeah really well yeah i
mean we all have our own definition of
beauty i i could literally hear our
producer amy groan through the
soundproof wall
it's true they're very pretty i bet he's
like no but you bring up this really
important point about sort of you know
the the attempt to create the the beauty
of math that it should it should fit
certain you know logics and systems
which is why we're all going crazy about
trying to figure out you know some
unifying theory to make sense of
einstein and and quantum physics i get
that but i guess in a sense when we're
talking about proof at this level we're
talking about simply observing certain
effects
and then theorizing the cause string
theory we see effects we need to make
sense of it and so let's theorize a
cause
and i would just say that
a lot of spirituality and the spiritual
you know point of view that that i share
that rain shares
is very much the same thing we observe
certain effects
and we theorize the cause i agree
um
and i i don't see
because i i don't really see a
difference i don't see why
the
the checks and balances of the
scientific method can't be applied uh to
that mode of inquiry also
[Music]
warby parker is committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores offering eyeglasses sunglasses
eye exams and contact lenses classes
start at 95 including prescription
lenses try warby parker's free home try
on program order five pairs of glasses
to try on at home for free for five days
there's no obligation to buy chips free
and includes a prepaid return shipping
label i found that uh filling out the
form online picking the glasses was just
so simple and uh easy and obvious did
you did you enjoy this experience reza i
tried on all five and here's the funny
thing
none of them were just right and so you
know what warby parker did they were
like no problem dude put it back in the
box pick five more here's the next five
and the second box arrived and i found
the one that i liked it was so easy i
couldn't believe it do you have an
iphone 10 or newer download the warby
parker app where you can use their
virtual try on allowing you to try on
eyeglasses seeing the realistic color
texture and size of each style using
just your phone
and if you prefer shopping in stores you
know what warby parker also has retail
locations throughout the united states
find your nearest store at
warbyparker.com
milkshake
warby parker partners with non-profits
like vision spring to ensure that for
every pair of glasses sold a pair is
distributed to someone in need and like
we said try this uh five pairs of
glasses at home for free yourself you
you're it's it's kind of unbelievable
all you got to do is go to
warbyparker.com
milkshake
the geeked podcast is your weekly energy
boost of the world's fandoms and stories
you love hosted by princess weeks author
youtuber and connoisseur of all things
sailor moon and buffy the vampire slayer
and tessa netting who's an actress
musical theater nerd and lover of all
fictional villains
each week they will break down the top
stories in the land of geekdom and then
take a deep dive into the lore of
netflix worlds bigger than our own
worlds like stranger things the umbrella
academy the witcher and many many many
more you'll also get to hear some of
your favorite actors and creatives talk
about fun behind the scenes tidbits and
of course what they are geeking out
about this podcast is a must listen for
anyone who is scouring twitter threads
and fan wikis dying to theorize and talk
about that new show they are obsessed
with
they've got interviews with actor joseph
quinn from stranger things four
emmy raver lampman who plays allison
hargreaves in umbrella academy podcast
host and cultural critic rose dammu and
many many more episode one releases on
thursday may 26 2022 new episodes of the
geeked podcast to come out weekly the
geeked podcast on apple podcasts spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts and
make sure to follow at netflix geeked on
twitter instagram and tick tock
[Music]
so um matt we end every uh episode with
some uh life's big questions
and
at no point in any uh interview that
we've ever done is that has this first
question been more relevant when do you
feel most connected with the universe
uh
staring at the night sky
and
being able to
imagine it as the the giant 3d universe
that i know it to be
[Music]
sometimes when you know the planets are
lined up right uh you see them all in
the same line with the moon uh if you if
you play some binoculars you see the
moons of jupiter in the same line uh as
well along the ecliptic and you can just
visualize
the solar system and you can imagine the
earth as one giant ball and then there's
the milky way and you can kind of get
this sense of this
this
vast vast perspective and and you're
just kind of
tiny and and spinning through it
uh
yeah that's fantastic and like literally
the most complete answer to that
question i think we've
ever had yeah beautiful now i know
you're a scientist and there's no
laboratory that can prove that you have
you have a soul but if you had a soul
how would you describe that soul in 10
words or less
i would say a
very curious and somewhat shy
seven-year-old child
nice
beautiful what is your biggest fear
that i'll realize i'm not nearly as
smart as i think i am
what is one thing you hate
marzipan
and
people asking about my star sign at
parties
[Laughter]
what do you want your final meal to be
uh probably a
no there's only one answer right now
marzipan
is the only right answer that's why it
was my final meal
uh
it's just like a like a really really
good coal oven pizza
with a really fluffy crispy edge
and what is your life's big question
the thing that keeps coming back to me
is why is there something rather than
nothing
uh
that's that's the thorny one
matt o'dowd uh you have a ton of fans uh
over here uh thank you so much that was
just so fascinating thank you for your
openness and your honesty too yeah that
was a brilliant discussion and uh i
really loved digging into some of those
intersections between science and
religions not at all how i thought the
conversation was gonna go today and uh
thanks for just jumping right in and
r.i.p your career yeah well i mean you
know now that i'm
on youtube it's already dead
thank you so much this was this was a
delight i love talking about this stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
fascinating conversation he was so
willing to go to some really uh personal
kind of places he was vulnerable yeah he
was willing to be stretched he was
willing to say i don't know exactly
that's exactly what i was going to say
long pauses i loved those long it was
very
contemplative yeah really really
terrific discussion but you know what it
got me thinking about is and this is
where i've
this is why i'm ultimately a theist
because i've talked about this before on
this show and on in my book and blah
blah blah other talk shows like i went
through a short phase as an atheist and
a very long phase i mean a long phase a
10-year phase as an agnostic
and what finally brought me around to
being a theist was really this
i couldn't
picture
a universe without some kind of creative
dynamic
force behind it i could it just didn't
make sense to me like yes i understand
what an atheist would say well it's not
provable and there's only science and
scientific laws and and matter and and
other measurable things um that can be
replicated etc but in my life it just
didn't make sense and and i think about
going through my life and having
consciousness and like the birth of my
son we almost lost my son he almost died
when he was born i mean a hair's breath
away and holding him that miracle of
life looking into his bright blue eyes
and in this shitty
hospital hallway
i think about being in love with my wife
having marital struggles that almost led
to divorce and some real darkness in my
life and and ups and downs and
experiencing beauty and pain and
connection and lack of connection and
darkness and light addiction issues lots
of different ups and downs and the
reason i bring all this personal stuff
into it is like as i've gone on the
roller coaster of my life
it just doesn't make sense to me on any
level in my heart in my gut in my head
instinctually he kept talking about like
these instinctual kind of uh what did he
say uh intuition intuition intuitive
kind of uh
processes that it the the universe
doesn't make any sense to me without
some kind of creative force behind it so
that's not very scientific but
i couldn't remain agnostic anymore and
why is it that the experience of being
alive is so not like being spock the
existence of being alive is laughter and
pain and tears and connection and fears
and awe and wonder and sadness and
isolation and alienation and and back to
connection again why do we live these
lives that are so seemingly emotional
and psycho-spiritual yeah and i think
this is what i loved about
matt o'dowd and the way that he talked
about science is i think that he
wouldn't discount what you just said you
know he would say that you have
had certain experiences and you have
made certain observations
that has created a level of intuition
in the way that you think about the
workings of the universe
and you have
allowed that intuition to lead you down
a certain path a path that you are more
than willing to question
and
even doubt and maybe even recognize as a
wrong turn here or there based on new
observations new experiences testing out
certain theories to see whether they
work or not i mean that that is the
scientific method
in a way and look neither of us are
sitting here saying science and religion
are the same thing we're not saying that
please don't email us about stuff like
that or just email us about stuff like
that we don't care we will take all of
your emails the point being is we're not
saying they're the same matt's not
saying they're the same
what we are saying is
that there is
a lot that
the scientific method
can benefit from sort of the spiritual
perspective sure and so much of the
spiritual perspective is informed by
what we would refer to as the scientific
method sure that the true
path of living a meaningful fulfilled
life
is to not constantly think of these two
things as being in opposition as being
in opposition right but to merge them
together to truly recognize that life
is lived in its fullest when one is
striving towards
transcendence two different tools toward
understanding right exactly um and you
know if we had more maddow dowds
i think there would be less of a sort of
this conflict between these two sides
indeed yeah what do you guys think uh
you scientific and or spiritual people
out there uh tell us what you think
about the conversation about science and
religion and how they can intersect or
not intersect are you a scientist who
believes in god
are you
a religious person who doesn't believe
in darwin please let us know what you
think you can find us on socials at reza
aslan and at rayne wilson make sure to
hashtag metaphysical thank you again to
our very special guest the very brave
scientist philosopher matt o'dowd make
sure to check out his youtube show pbs
space time it's pretty awesome and we
will see you in the next universe
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa de jazz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey cradwell sarah
pellegrini mary phillip sandy and shelby
sandlin original music by jeff tang and
scott tang
[Music]
which one is more racist if i said the
shrimp on the barbie or if i said the
dingo ate my baby didn't do it maybe
my baby just to be clear is a true story
something funny about a dingo eating a
baby
i can't be racist against a fellow white
man
i don't think i don't think that's how
it works
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you